Lola asked her classmates their favorite
type of movie and graphed the results
all right so it says that so it says 20
people said their favorite type of movie
was comedy six people said their
favorite type of movie was scary
ten people said their favorite type of
movie was adventure ten people also said
their favorite type of movies cartoons
and then sixteen people said their
favorite type of movies a mystery all
right so let's read the questions here
so which of the following types of
movies were picked by fewer than
fourteen people so fewer than fourteen
people so more than fourteen picked
comedy or mystery so this line right
over here would be 14 so fewer than 14
or scary adventure cartoon this was six
people ten people in 10 people scary
adventure and cartoon so we want to pick
scary adventure and cartoon these three
had less than 14 people pick them so
let's do a couple more of these let's do
a couple more puppy party place graph
the number of dogs that came in each
weekday so let's see 80 dogs came in on
Monday 160 dogs came in on Tuesday 80
dogs came in on Wednesday 140 dogs came
in on Thursday and then Friday was a
very popular day 180 dogs came into the
puppy party place on Friday all right so
what are they asking us on which day did
the same number of dogs come to party
puppy party play as on Monday and
Wednesday combined all right so let's
see Monday and Wednesday combined so on
Monday we had 80 puppies come there or
80 dogs and on Wednesday we had 80 dogs
and they're saying which which day had
the same as Monday and Wednesday
combined so Monday and Wednesday
combined would be 80 plus 80 which would
be 160 so on which of these days is it
160 dogs come well we see it right over
here 160 dogs that was on Tuesday and
only on Tuesday so Tuesday let's do a
few more of these
desert zone or desert desert zone asked
its customers about their favorite ice
cream flavor and graphed the results so
175 customer said vanilla 225 said
chocolate what was 75 said strawberry
and 200 said cookie dough all right how
many more customers pick the most
popular flavor than the least popular
flavor all right so the most popular
flavor was chocolate those 225 and the
least popular Flav favored flavor it's
late to the least popular flavor it's a
tongue twister was 75 so how many more
picked the most popular than the least
popular well the most popular is 225 the
least popular was 75 so it's 225 minus
75
let's see 225 minus 25 would be 200
minus 50 would be 175 minus 75 would be
150 so we get 150 customers and once
again we're saying that 150 more
customers picked chocolate the most
popular favorite flavor than the least
popular another way you could do it is
you can look at the least popular in the
most populous a well how many more do I
have to add to the least popular to get
to the most popular and you see 25 50 75
100 125 150 each of these lines is 25
more so there you have it 150 more
customers liked the most popular flavor
chocolate then the least popular flavor